Mad, how you doing?
>> Hello.
>> Hello there.
>> Hi. I'm good. How are you?
>> I'm pretty good. So, what's on your
mind?
>> If you remember me, I came to the stage
like a long time ago and I did my
research about Christianity and all
that. And I'm happy to say that uh I
took my shahada to Christianity.
>> You took your shahada to Christianity?
>> Yeah.
>> You be you're saying you became a
Christian?
>> Yeah.
>> What? How long ago was it that we spoke?
cuz I I don't remember man.
>> I think four four months ago it was live
>> David Good was there and uh
uh that brother and sister was there. I
don't remember the name.
>> Yeah. Gi giant DLC.
>> Yeah. Giant DLC.
>> Wow.
>> Yeah. I've been watching I've been
watching your content for a long time
and I've been reading the Bible and yeah
like it resonates with me.
>> Praise God, dude. That's so awesome.
That is that's incredible. Well, I'm uh
I'm going have to go back to the stream
and check it out. Um I have a guy who is
able to find like clips on YouTube
references, you know, like in archives.
So, I'm definitely going to check it
out. 100. I know you're listening. Try
to try to find when his name is Malad.
Malad. Was that your name on when you
came on last time, too? Was it Malad?
>> Yeah.
>> Malad Cassmi.
>> Yeah,
>> for sure. Yeah. Yeah. 100. Try to find
that clip. He says it was in a David
Wood a stream I did with David Wood and
Giant DLC. So try to find try to find
that man. That's that dude. That's
awesome, man. Four about four months
ago. That's incredible. Praise God for
you, man. Thanks for coming up and
sharing that. That's that's a blessing,
man.
>> Thank you. Yeah. And I've been I've been
going to the church like I can
experience it in real life. You know
what I mean?
>> Exactly. Exactly. That's the difference.
That's the big difference is that when
you're walking with Christ truly, you ex
you experience him in real time. He's
really it's really it's real. It's
relational.
>> A lot of a lot of people are like scared
of it, but I'm here to say it's not it's
not something scary. If you really open
your heart
>> and like walk around just with open
heart and honesty, everything's going to
be all right,
>> man. That's awesome. Praise God, dude.
You Yeah. you bless the stream. What
would you say for uh the Muslims who are
listening, you know, cuz you know, you
you you have Muslims that probably
secretly have doubts, you know, but
they're afraid to express them or afraid
to investigate them, you know, um or to
talk about them with anyone. They're
surrounded by, you know, their Muslim
communities. What would you say to them?
uh
uh I can understand them because they
truly believe what is written in in
their book in the Quran and the hadith
but if you compare it to the Old
Testament and New Testament it's not
nothing nothing is mentioned there you
know it's just a claim
>> exactly exactly
>> if you go back by the history like
Christianity history is way way before
and they they know what they're doing
they know how to they say oh our book is
preserved and all that
>> but they can do it too
>> they can
>> exactly
>> they have the originals and they go by
the text and nothing is mentioned about
no no Ahmed no Quran no nothing
>> that's deep man that's deep I hope that
you guys are hearing this man this is a
new brother in the faith he's a new
brother in Christ he left Islam a little
while ago now and he's telling you guys
man
>> I can say is just open your eyes kingdom
of heaven is Yeah.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. God bless you, bro. That's right,
guys. You guys heard it here.
>> The kingdom of heaven is at hand.
>> We need to stop the hate. Like today,
the weather is good. It's sunny and
everywhere, everyone's going work,
coming back. Like, it's good.
>> Praise God. And he just sent me the
clip, too, at the 39 minute mark. So,
what video is this one? Okay. Yeah, I
remember this day. Yeah. But I also
understand the situation of Palestine
and Israel and all of that, but those
are all politics game. Has nothing to do
with the religion.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> Yeah, man. Well, I want to just say stay
strong, man. Um, welcome to the family
of Christ. I'm so happy that you came
and shared that with me, bro. I I
remember you now. He pulled up uh he pul
he showed me the clip and uh yeah,
that's you right there. Two two months
ago, bro. two months ago you popped up
on the stream. Yeah.
>> Yeah. And
>> can Muslims finally solve this dilemma?
Yeah.
>> My connection is not good today. Well,
once I get some Wi-Fi, then I'll come
back to the live stream again. But thank
you for bringing me up.
>> Yeah. God bless you, man. Thanks for
coming up again, bro.
>> Thank you so much. Have a blessed day.
Have a good day.
>> You too, man. See you.
>> Wow. Yeah, guys. So, Malad pops up at
the uh on the stream that I had with
David Wood and them. It's called, "Can
Muslims finally solve this dilemma?" And
around the 39 minute mark, we're having
a discussion with him, he pops up and
we're having a discussion with him. So
that was two months ago. Two months ago,
he popped up on our stream. We showed
him the Islamic dilemma, showed him, you
know, he's been reading the Bible,
started investigating,
and ended up leaving Islam. Notice the
context, guys. The context is that Malad
showed up on a stream where we were
going over the Islamic dilemma which
then led him to investigate
and and think about Christianity and
read the Bible and now he's a Christian.
Glory to God. The Holy Spirit drew him
in. Look at that. So, if you guys need
any more proof that this argument is
airtight and is extremely powerful, this
is another evidence right here. Another
evidence. Another Muslim has left Islam
starting with the Islamic dilemma.
Incredible. Amanda, what's going on?
>> Hello, Avery. It's late. It's quarter to
1, but I can't sleep. So, I've just seen
your lives on. I just got a couple of
couple more questions. I'm so close. I'm
so close but not quite there yet. So,
I've just got a couple more questions.
>> Sure. Sure.
>> All right. So, I've been told, and
please correct me if this is wrong, that
the gospels that were written were not
actually written. Well, originally they
said the names Matthew, Mark, Luke, and
John were not the names of those people.
And there's no evidence that they were
actually um like witnesses of Jesus that
actually ever met him. They were just
stories that were written by people
later after Jesus had died. Just what is
your opinion on that?
>> Yeah. So that would be demonstrably
false. And here's why. Because we have
2,000 years, Amanda, of church history.
2,000 years of church history where you
have from generation to generation
there's heretics that's coming up people
that are coming up with new ideas new
concepts even with so-called gospels
gospel of Mary Peter Barry Mary
Magdalene Thomas
>> Barnabas Bar you know all of these
different types of gospels are coming
out right
>> and none of them are ever accepted not
even close not one they're always
disputed
unanimously by the church never accepted
any of these gnostic gospels. But when
we look at Matthew, Mark, Luke, and
John, there was never ever any dispute
within 2,000 years of church history
>> on the authorship of those writings.
>> Okay?
>> All the church fathers and the bishops
and those who succeeded the apostles and
their uh students and their students and
their all of them always agreed. Matthew
wrote Matthew. Luke wrote Luke. Mark
wrote Mark. John wrote John. All of
them.
>> Okay. Okay. Okay.
>> So, it's it's crazy when people come up
and say, "Yeah, well, actually, no one
actually knows these authors. We've
never known them.
>> You we have quotes from Arena and uh
Papus and Ignatius and uh Polycarbon.
All of these guys, Clement of Rome, like
we got all these quotes from these
people,
>> all the early church fathers." Yeah.
>> Exactly.
>> Mhm. So the evidence in history is on
our side.
>> Okay, that's really good. Um, thank you
for that. The other one was that I'm not
sure which books, but there's two of the
gospels and one where the census was
done and then there was another I think
it was the reign of King Herod where the
times don't match. I'm not sure if
you've heard that argument. um the
census happened at a different time of
when Herod was reigning and they said
there's like six six years or six
centuries something between th those two
differences. Um they said the census was
done later but when I looked into the
argument of it um it said that the the
census that was done might not have been
one that was recorded but was told about
in the Bible just not recorded in
history. Um, I don't know if you've
heard of that argument before.
>> I've I've heard not in detail like this,
so I wouldn't I wouldn't be able to give
you a detailed answer. Um, but let me
see if I can find something cuz I
believe inspiring philosophy.
>> I'm sure it said something like
>> on the census.
>> Something to do with the census and the
reign of King Herod were at different
times.
>> The census and the Bible inspiring
philosophy. Inspiring philosophy. Let me
see if he did something on this cuz he
this channel he he tackles all the
apparent contradictions and all this
stuff.
>> Was that inspiring for us?
>> I love this dude's channel. Let me see
>> that popped up on Spotify actually.
Check that one out.
>> Okay. Did Luke misdate the senses of
Okay. Well, his videos are kind his
video on this is kind of long. It's not
short.
>> That's my So that's on YouTube.
>> I'll tell you what. Here is
>> I'll check that one out.
>> Here is Is he So he has a 38 minute
video on it and a 9minute video on it.
I'm going to watch this later. So I
watch it myself and I'mma put this in
the private link for you. Copy this.
>> That's great. Thank you.
>> And uh watch that before you go to bed
tonight and see what you think.
>> Yeah. All right. Brilliant.
>> Okay.
>> That's great. Okay.
>> Oh, sorry. Hold on. I can't hear you
right now. My volume is tripping.
>> There you go. All right. What' you say?
>> Can you hear me now? Um,
>> yeah.
>> So, it's like I want to believe Jesus is
God, but there's still things that make
me doubt it. And, and it's probably
because I'm listening to Islamic
channels as well, which just lead me to
more confusion.
>> And at the end of the day, it's trying
to get my head around the fact that that
God can be finite and infinite at the
same time because what the argument is
that those things are incompatible with
each other. can't be both at the same
time. But then I'm kind of thinking,
well, can't God do anything? Can he not
be finite as a human being and infinite
as God at the same time?
>> Yeah. And so what that of course I I
don't I wouldn't understand the logical
issue there. You you have the the the
problem would be again and like this
keeps coming up like if if God were if
we were saying that God in his divine
essence was finite and infinite at the
same time in his divine essence
>> then that's a problem. You we can't say
that the divine essence is finite. It's
not right by very nature it's infinite.
But then if the person takes on a human
nature
>> then he can you know interact with with
the finite in that way right that he you
can say that he has a nature that is
finite not his divine nature his human
nature is finite
>> and that's what he um how that's how he
interacted with the world in so there
shouldn't be a like logically it's not a
problem you know okay it's it's just
about
>> do you do you believe him now or not you
know Yeah. Okay. Yeah, that makes sense.
It's just that that kind of the books
I've been reading, they were like
saying, well,
>> you know, the fact God was a human, he
he got hungry, he could get hurt, and
that makes him weak because God would
not be able to do those things. If he
was God, you can't be you can't have
hunger, you can't have thirst, you can't
feel pain if you're God.
>> Yeah. But they're they're then confl
they're still they're still eliminating
the distinction between the divine
nature and the human nature. So if
you're saying that God is getting
hungry, God is can be hurt or God can
bleed or sneeze,
>> this would all be pertaining to his
human nature that he takes on
>> that he willfully uh operates in,
>> not pertaining to his divine essence. So
if if they could actually argue against
what we what we believe, then let's do
that. Stop arguing against something we
don't believe. We don't believe that God
in his divine essence can be hurt, gets
hungry, can bleed, can die.
>> No.
>> Yeah. Okay. So if I decide, okay, Jesus
is God, what do I do? Do I just say it
or
>> Yeah. So what basically what Well, this
what the Let me just I'll read you the
Bible. This is what This what the Bible
say to do? You know what the only thing
we do around here, Amanda?
>> Yeah.
>> We just read around here, girl. All
right. So, in Romans 10, uh,
9 to 11. And I'll put it on the screen,
too, so we can all look at it together.
Oops. Romans chap 10 9-11. So, this is
what this is what the Bible said. Hold
on, let me make it big cuz I can't even
see it. Is that big enough for you? Can
you see it?
>> Yes.
>> All right.
>> So, Romans 10 9-11. This is what it
says. It says, "Because
if you confess with your mouth that
Jesus is Lord and believe in your heart
that God raised him from the dead, you
will be saved." For with the heart one
believes and is justified,
and with the mouth one confesses and is
saved. For the scripture says, "Everyone
who believes in him will not be put to
shame." So all you got to do, Amanda,
when you get that conviction and you're
convinced in your heart and you truly
believe, you confess. Tell them, "Lord,
I believe that you're the Lord. I
believe that you are my God. I believe
you died for my sins. I believe the
Father raised you up on the on the third
day, and I trust in you and you alone
for my salvation." Okay.
>> That's what you That's what you you
express that out of your own heart just
like this. This is just a model.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
>> Okay.
>> I'm very close. I will say I have tried
before to kind of leave, but what
happens is I'm going to be honest.
>> I get a lot of Muslim people contacting
me on my WhatsApp groups and in on Tik
Tok saying absolutely horrible things
about me,
you know, calling me a disbeliever and
all this.
>> And then they're like, "Let me meet with
you. let me talk with you and then they
they end up convincing me again. Um, but
then I keep watching your channel and it
just makes so much sense. So, what are
these? When are you when are you next on
live? When you
>> I I'll be I'll most likely be live
tomorrow again. Same time.
>> What's your time zone? Mine's different
to yours.
>> So, what we two hours So, two hours like
two hours before 1:00 a.m. I'm 1:00 a.m.
here. So,
>> you're 1 a.m. right now?
>> Yeah. So around 12 11 like uh 11 your
time. Is that too late?
>> What I'm going to do then? Yeah. Yeah,
that's true. What I'm going to do, I'm
going to give it some thought. I'm going
to read my Bible and if I feel ready,
I'm going to come on tomorrow and do it
if that's all right.
>> Praise God. Yeah. Just let let it be in
your heart.
>> I can can break the shackles. Praise
God.
>> Of course. Yeah. Definitely, Amanda.
Definitely. and I wish I found you two
years ago. So yeah, but
>> thank you very much. Hopefully see you
tomorrow then.
>> Okay, I'll see you tomorrow. I'll go
live just for you because now now it was
I didn't know if I was So now I'll go
live in general and if if you come you
know
>> just keep you in your prayers
>> for sure. I got you. Bye.
>> Oh man, God's hand is really on this
ministry. God's hand is truly truly on
this ministry, guys. All glory to God.
Oh, glory to God. We have disbelievers
left and right. Not just Muslims, Sikhs,
agnostics, oneness modalists left and
right. Hebrew Israelites coming to
Christ through this ministry. Man, I
would not I I I couldn't do be doing
anything else. I would wouldn't do
anything else than this right here. I
can do this for the rest of my life. And
as long as breath is in my body and God
is has this his call this call in my
life, I will do this for the rest of my
life. As long as I have breath, I will
minister for the kingdom. Because we see
the fruit that it's bearing. We see the
fruit that that that it's bearing. The
fruit that God, not me, not anybody else
that's part of the team, but the fruit
that God is growing through our
obedience, through us just being
obedient. He could be using anybody. He
can be he can pull out anybody. I'm just
humbled and and honored that he's
allowing me to work for him, work for
the kingdom, and produce the fruit that
he's producing. Man, glory to God.
Jesus. Jesus. Lord, you're good. Lord,
you are so good. Uh, I think I want to
end it there, guys. I want to end it
there because if I stay on any longer, I
can't let y'all see me like this, man. I
got I got I got street cred. I got a
reputation. So, I can't let y'all see me
like this. So, I think I'm just going to
go ahead and read a few super chats and
then uh call it a night. Watch some
people some people cook or